don't know about you but my favorite
thing on tick-tock is the food
and in the past year you've probably
seen how-to videos
for the tortilla wrap the mini pancake
cereal and the whipped coffee
these delicious videos got a combined
30.9 million views so
clearly this is so exciting and i love
this too because i'm a parent so i'm
like what's the kids doing on tick tock
and i just like to be up in the know and
our next guest
is back on the show for her second time
first time in person
to show us the newest and yummiest tik
tok
food trend please welcome lifestyle
expert friend of the show michelle park
i'm excited and you're real i'm here in
person
so cool i'm so excited because this
is the hottest trend right now there are
two
it's the tomato feta pasta
like how would you describe it it's
everywhere everybody's making this baked
feta pasta people have started swapping
out the ingredients with
fun new ones it's like it's got taken on
a whole new life
but this is the original and it is
delicious okay
so we're also gonna maybe touch on the
accordion potato
which is also trending like crazy
but the reason i was so excited to do
this is because i haven't done it yet
i'm seeing it everywhere and i want to
be in the club so
teach me so drew we're going to start
with this big empty
casserole dish and you're going to take
your grape tomatoes
or cherry tomatoes if that's what you
have and just throw them in there and
then throw your shallots in there i mean
there there's no like
real technique to this you're just
throwing everything together
so you kind of spread it around but the
whole point is just have fun with it
right and then take your olive oil and
just give it a good drizzle
we're also going to do a little salt and
pepper as much as you normally like
and then if you're into the spice you
can sprinkle a little red pepper on
there
i like i'm into spice and now make
yourself a little hole in the middle
because we're going to put
our feta cheese right in there okay and
now you can put your thyme that you've
got there on top
i like to put a little bit more red
pepper flake just for good measure it
also makes it look nice and pretty now
all you need to do with this is stick it
in the oven at 400 for 40 minutes
440. got it and then it's going to come
out it's going to look like this so now
we have this guy beautiful
and all you have to do now is just stick
your pasta in this and we're going to
mix it up and you will see how creamy
and just cody and beautiful this feta
turns out
now oh my gosh
okay yeah so so if yours is now nicely
incorporated there's a little
you could eat out of the fancy plate but
i think we should just eat out of the
ones that we made
um that's that's the stuff
[Music]
all right now take me through the
potatoes michelle all right let's do the
other
hot hot hot tick tock trend can't get
away from
and it's called accordion potatoes yes
because you can kind of stretch them out
and then push them back together like an
accordion
so i'm going to show you how to do this
um the the tip that i have for you
is since we're going to be cutting them
but we don't want to cut them all the
way through if you have chopsticks you
can
like kind of place them like this so you
don't end up chopping through the
oh i see oh i totally get it it's like a
barrier
yes it's like a we call it like chopping
potatoes for dummies so first you're
going to cut it
just straight down in kind of close
together
okay michelle this chopstick barrier
is so brilliant thank you no really this
is a brilliant hack
all right so if you've done the first
side you're just going to flip it over
and
now when you cut it you're going to cut
on a diagonal instead of straight down
okay because this is how you're going to
get it to kind of
fan out okay diagonal yes
this is cool so what you're going to do
next is you're going to skewer it this
this part is uh potentially dangerous so
i just recommend anyone who's trying to
do it at home make sure you're wearing
gloves or something so that you don't
poke your finger because you could draw
some blood
um and once it is skewered it will look
like this
look i'm just gonna use my stomach
what am i doing wrong michelle it's very
very difficult
to actually get the skewer in there so
you want to kind of
slowly work it through gosh
well that's the new technique
okay so i'm going to show you how to
butter this thing up
so we have butter italian seasoning
garlic thyme you know
you can actually put any herbs you want
in here so if you whatever you're into
so whatever is preferential
yes butter is the most important part
well yeah
so now this you're gonna lay them all
flat on a baking sheet
20 minutes on each side at 400 degrees
and then they come out
looking like that okay and then
now we get to actually eat it
[Music]
back to the pasta you know this one i
got
this one is really carefree
and like less intimidating
but it was fun to do it with you drew
well apparently i can't do it and i just
have to accept that so i'm gonna drown
my problems in these gorgeous noodles
that are
dressed in feta and tomato and michelle
i can't thank you enough for making me
feel like i am in the club
thank you this is what i always do i
just eat and then i can't
do anything thank you michelle
thank you drew